bill bird patrice o'neill keith robinson
jim norton colin quinn myself
um when i say we would sit at this table
we would sit at this table for four to
five hours and it would be nothing
but beautiful trashions to one another
this is something that you're doing to
uh this is going to raise money
for patrice o'neill one of the great
great funniest stand-up funniest comic i
ever saw
unfortunately passed away i'm gonna try
to get through this
and um
sorry that's all right you're gonna by
doing this you're gonna raise
money for his mom money for his mom and
his wife and uh
this is huge this is huge
i just want to say we missed the hell
out of patrice man he's he made everyone
in this room better
and uh it kills us to this day i just
want to tell you a person
yeah on the i missed the days of him
just walking down that long hall
yeah because you know you're you had to
be on your game and he was going to
[ __ ] bring it
and you also knew that it was like all
right this the next two hours of radio
oh yeah yeah i can become a fan now
absolutely right right you could sit
back and just watch
it was amazing watching him do radio
just absolutely amazing
i missed talking and hearing silence
from my right and then looking over and
just seeing that look
people just scrunched up face look
people don't realize like
how many bad jokes you gotta wait like
he would be looking over like everybody
else would be laughing and then you just
you just
felt a bit yeah you felt this head turn
and then you make that face and you just
shrug your shoulder i know it's not up
to you
but this is all like this is the talent
oh you think you knocked one out of the
park and then he's just
um sometimes he would do it just because
you got a good laugh
right right and he saw you happy like
look at him enjoying himself
for a second was that
but he would let you know man when you
were being funny when you got a laugh
out of patrice
amazing feeling yeah yeah so like you
got called up to the major
right we went up to montreal in that
truck and we had to go through customs
right so you have to pull over and get
out of your truck and go into a building
and it's me and i still don't remember
who the other comics were but we were
all white
patrice is the only black guy and uh
they take all our passports and stuff
and then they go
ladies like no one of you has a record
or something
all all four of us look at patrice
and he's like what you mf is looking at
and and
the lady behind the count is trying not
to laugh you know i don't know why
to this day i don't know what was in his
whatever just to prove that stereotypes
aren't true at all
the other comic was me and i was like
but uh
so we we we get back we he i
i'm busting his chops because i'm i'm
really the headliner because
when you host the nasty show your name
is on the market right you're the
other you know you're the one that's
selling tickets shimmel hosted it when i
did it and bobby slate was the mayor
right right but because patrice is
arguing with me because he goes on last
every night
and then on the way up he's saying man
well if that's the way you see it man
and i'm like the way i see it that's how
it is man don't tell me
i'm the headliner and we get up there
and i you know do my stick up front
and then he goes on last after a killer
show and just destroys
just takes it to a different level you
know geraldo colin quinn nick depaolo
jim norton rich voss patrice o'neill
keith robinson
bobby kelly it was insane and if you
came down there and you wore the wrong
shirt
it was [ __ ] over so the funniest guys
i ever met
yeah i ever met like they they were uh
they weren't real patrice was the king
like you walked in if he wasn't there
you were relieved
and there were nights when you were on a
roll and you know you were you were
killing someone at the table and then he
starts walking in like your heart would
sink
oh [ __ ] here we go here we go
here we go now it's the real deal dad's
home
eddie if said the funniest thing one
time he goes dude he goes sometimes like
i'll come walking into the cellar
and he goes up he would just as he
walked in patrice would be killing the
table and then just see
eddie come in it'd be like and just
start yelling over at him and he said
and eddie said that i would literally
think
[ __ ] he saw me and and
and then that's when the the whole thing
kind of took off and like a tough crowd
came out of that
how about you kev uh you know what if i
wanted anyone to be president i would
want to be shaq
because shaq can do whatever the hell he
wants shaq can call you in right now
and tell him that he wants to bomb
france they're going to say but why shaq
they didn't do anything uh i don't know
i don't like the basketball team i think
the basketball team stinks
i want to drop a bomb on him i want to
dunk it
he called me with that shack do you
think this shack is gonna be good yeah
the comedian that you remind me of do
you know who i'm speaking of
uh no he was
my favorite community and he passed away
a couple years ago patrice o'neil
the reason i love patrice was uh he had
his own truth
and he was going to tell you and he
wasn't going to take any prisoners
and that's a giant void to fill patrice
o'neill because i felt he was the
funniest guy in the world when he
passed away but uh yeah our great friend
patrice o'neill passed away man and
we're all
absolutely [ __ ] devastated and i'm
gonna try not to get emotional here but
he has a um he has a uh a dvd
called elephant in the room makes a
great christmas gift
and it would really help out his mom and
he also has a new cd out
on itunes called mr p and if you guys
could do me a huge
favor do you want to repay me for the
podcast on any level
could you please buy that man's work
because i got to tell you man that guy
no joke is the funniest [ __ ] dude i
ever met in my life and it's not even
close
it's not even close and you can't even
that dude was so funny like
even his stand-up work only just
captures like a sliver
of how [ __ ] funny that guy was that
guy i'm telling you
like him walking in to a deli to buy a
newspaper was funnier than most
comedians
i ever met and it's just uh it's just
[ __ ]
awful i'm still in shock that he's uh
he's not here anymore and um
i don't know when the time's right i'll
be telling some some of his stories
because
of the i'm telling you i can tell you
this there's not going to be another one
and that's the thing that probably hurts
the most is that
there's no [ __ ] way i'm ever gonna
meet someone like that again in my life
all right okay no crying on the podcast
here we go plowing ahead
so if you guys could [ __ ] do that for
me i would really appreciate it
um yeah all right so
here we go push it down bill push it
down do you ever
worry that maybe you're putting out this
energy and you're manifesting something
like some sort of an attack on you
because you're constantly dwelling on it
and you always have this gun
and patrice goes joe believe in magic
don't believe me conjuring up the world
hey man a positive energy
just starts laughing see he's magic joke
magic
most like most of my friends that are
comics most
are are at best okay
and usually awkward or bad at talking to
women
yeah a lot of comics most comics are
yeah yeah yeah that's usually like
guys that came up weren't no no i can't
patrice
trace was ridiculous patrice could
actually insult them all the way into
the bedroom
that's so crazy they would just be
walking and going i know i know you're
right
but those are the broken girls and
broken girls you can always manipulate
sure listen right no let me tell you
it's still work yeah it's just something
that women won't understand because you
guys don't have to convince people to
have sex with you
that's all they're great things yeah but
like uh bobby kelly back in the day
phenomenal at talking to check
phenomenal really phenomenal nah
like there were legends in new york i
was not part of that
you're not legend crew no dude come on
ron i look like ron howard it was like i
just always had to work
but uh there was yeah there was
i don't i don't i don't want to like you
know but patrice
patrice i had heard about i mean even a
few other years ago
about his uh you know i mean i knew he
was gifted obviously i mean him on
here stand up on shows but i heard
stories about him
with women about how that was ridiculous
yeah it was ridiculous
it made no sense and he was he he was so
good at making them uncomfortable that
they
ignored all of his imperfections that
were
just right in front of their face like
yeah one time we was sitting i know i've
told this i think i told this one on
opinion anthony uh
we were sitting down the cellar this is
one of his classics and there was
three women they were excited and was a
loud bar and they were talking so you
know women when they talk loudly
yeah and he just he just yelled over at
one he's like ma'am
miss ma'am ma'am and she finally looks
up she's gorgeous
and he go and she looks she's like what
he goes your voice
she goes is it loud and he goes it's
piercing and
and we just started laughing at her and
it took her a second to regroup
and i don't know what happened five
minutes later all three of them gorgeous
are standing around patrice and he has
them auditioning
to see who has the best phone sex voice
and they're doing it
because he had them all convinced that
despite
how they looked their their voices were
so annoying that most guys
actually secretly didn't like them
wanted them to shut up
and didn't want to hear their opinions
yeah and they bought into that
yeah and next thing you know they're
trying to prove to him that they can be
sexy and they were like you know they
were all
nines yeah like and nine in new york too
yeah yeah yeah
super smooth yeah so that was uh
incredible i saw my time walked up to a
girl and she was
she was gorgeous and she had this little
scar on her forehead
and he comes walking up with his big
stupid finger she was sitting down and
he goes i like that and he pointed right
at her scar and she was like mortified
and that and that's just how we would
you just started off balance with him
yeah and then he just kept pushing your
shoulder at verbally every time you'd
start to regain your footing he would
find something else
and he would just trash you for an hour
and then you loved him
yeah now some nights you hated him you
wanted to you literally wanted to kill
him
like he would make you so many would
start laughing at you it was brutal i
beat him once
in 20 years of knowing him at the point
which is inevitable i mean it's
inevitable at least once you're gonna
win
yeah i just got him we were on the phone
it was a three-way call me him and bobby
i think and i was using all of his
techniques which which made him mad
and then he was off his game he didn't
talk to me for like three days he was so
upset
but uh but it was literally like you
know if they when they only drag some
idiot out of the stands and he hits a
half court shot sure
you drag enough idiots out there
eventually someone's gonna hit it yeah
um that's basically what happened but
other than that i think yes i was
basically one
in 17 000 conversations with him
no he pounded yeah we used to gang up on
him and he could still
we like gang up on him and you'd get him
for a little bit
it's just like uh i i can't it's like
one of those video games you just can't
defeat
unless you go online and you get the
cheats the cheats where we would we
would gang up
and try to gang up on him and and he
yeah
he would still effortlessly and then
what would you'd hope you'd have
solidarity with the person
that you ganged up on and then he would
get he'd get you with something
and then your friend just had to start
laughing at you and then you were done
then you were done and then they wanted
patrice to stop trashing them
so then they would pile on with patrice
and then it was brutal so then you'd
have to try to get it off you
on to somebody else and you just oh it
was yeah that's so awful
it's so awesome sounds terrible every
single no but it made us better i
used to go downstairs at the seller and
they would be upstairs and you'd have
some new bit
and somebody would hate your joke like
keith would hate it or patrice would
hate it
it just as long as one person hated it
they would bring it up and start saying
how awful a joke it was
and then everybody would pile on and
then you have to be like [ __ ] you i'm
still doing the joke and then you go
downstairs to do the joke and everyone
would be standing
staring at you during your set dude and
it was uh
it was brutal and even if you committed
and it got
the joke got a laugh patrice had a laugh
that would
was so loud he could shut the crowd up
yeah and he knew when to laugh
he just knew what he was doing yeah he
was he was a nightmare
yeah yeah yeah he was a nightmare i
loved him to death but he when he was
on you it was a [ __ ] nightmare and it
didn't yeah it didn't end when you went
on stage
right it was jesus yeah well that's why
we look at all these [ __ ]
people now like i can't even relate to
him like this whole new
the new thing it's like nobody trap i
feel like this old guy like hey you know
we used to give each other [ __ ]
oh yeah it wasn't supportive but it was
supportive because you were uh
no you're helping each other out with
that yeah for sure well that certainly
made like
somebody heckling you after that point
of sitting there having norton
keith voss and patrice on your ass at
the same time and then kevin hart came
along
if you had all five of them trashing you
like when you went on stage and somebody
heckled you was hilarious yeah
because that you you just don't with
[ __ ] five of the professional
professionals yeah
yeah it's so professional yeah that's
what you're describing
is so foreign to me in comedy there were
comics who literally avoided going to
the cellar just because of that or they
would they would just go downstairs and
do their set and then they'd leave they
wouldn't go upstairs to the table
really yeah and the whole table came
about i think because of patrice
because patrice got kicked out of the
club
so we loved him so much we just would go
where he was so he would be like
in front of the club so we would all
just go outside
and uh they didn't know how to deal
whenever they were telling him he had to
leave
and he was just like oh else what he's
like you'll never
ever ever never play this club he's like
he's like i'm already kicked out of here
[ __ ] you know so we were all
just laughing
so then they got kicked out of the club
though like out of the seller the seller
kicked him out
why i forget why i forget why he just
for being patrice right yeah